everywhere you look you can do a jab you
can do this
Jack wait you didn't retreat before you
go out there you passed now go
oh gosh happening I don't know what's
going on hey hey buddy let's dance
since instance yeah yeah in the club in
the club touch my sorry a turkey dance
ah the cake is a large Scott achievement
Oh
oh my god God MLG MLG ah hey hey hey who
said we should play this game
uh not me at least oh thank you no I was
sitting because of you haha
can someone please does got it oh please
oh he's got it he's got ass good [ __ ] is
[ __ ] folks wait oh no break it out of
it I like to get you magic yeah
ken Ken Ken Ken ah Jesus Christ al the
mainly shrieks Oh deaf and terror all
right watch this
no I'm [ __ ] god that [ __ ]
you're supposed to like notice was a
yes
to me then hey I got this one don't even
worry don't anymore you guys
damn it ah shorty my [ __ ] yeah blah
feet tha ha ha dad beautiful oh you guys
dude dude yo oh rekt rekt O'Shea not
over ah ha
what the [ __ ] was that [ __ ] ice the
[ __ ] eyes can just oh god I'm
stuck no [ __ ] you
oh I slid yeah what the [ __ ] was that
hey hey almost magic Thanks
thank you very much ah are you scared
damn in my eye you just run smooth oh
sweet a sweet folder whoa hey hey hey
donation decoration I'm sorry I will get
racial later [ __ ] a lot of give without
you honey way hey do you want to play a
game yes first [ __ ] finish it no
don't don't do it again wait don't tell
me to live my laughs I do live your life
the way you attend it yeah
ah you're gonna make it out alive you're
not leaving you behind
gotta you gotta get out of there Gary
you must go uh yeah I would not move on
without you you're gonna make it out of
here that are so true you better keep
going I will not tell your wife now you
not me that that